lists in the year that III turned 20 we
saw a lot of big gaming announcements
Square Enix surprised everyone by
revealing the 90s classic final fantasy
seven would be getting a next-gen remake
it's something fans had been calling for
for more than a decade but few expected
it would ever really happen meanwhile
Sony said it's missing in action title
The Last Guardian would be coming out
after all there was big news from EA who
announced the fourth entry in the Mass
Effect franchise and microsoft revealed
that xbox 360 games would now work on
xbox one something much demanded by fans
so those were the big announcements of
2015 but what about the games releases
let the legend come back to life metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain came out
to wide critical acclaim it made a
hundred and seventy nine million dollars
on its launch day star wars battlefront
was released ahead of the latest film in
the sci-fi saga and it became the
fastest-selling game based on the
franchise while the much-anticipated
fallout 4 shipped 12 million copies in
just 24 hours but it was the witcher 3
that scooped the year's biggest
accolades the open-world RPG claimed
five awards at the golden joysticks
including game of the year and it was
another year another fifa this
installment saw the inclusion of female
players for the first time also flying
the flag for women in gaming was Lara
Croft the iconic Explorer was back for
the second installment in the revamped
Tomb Raider franchise and there was a
return for everybody's favorite Italian
plumber Super Mario turned 30 and
Nintendo celebrated the big occasion by
releasing Super Mario maker there was
also some sad news from the Japanese
games maker the company's president and
CEO Satoru Iwata passed away at 55 2015
was a year of milestones in the gaming
world Sony's ps4 was the company's
fastest selling console ever and YouTube
gamer PewDiePie became the owner of the
first channel to hit 10 billion views so
it was a busy 2015 but what will next
year hold many are predicting it could
be time for virtual reality to take
off so 2016 could be just as eventful
Chris Cregan Sky News